there aren't many graveyards in San
Francisco too actually
a small one admission Dolores Church and
a military one at the Presidium San
Francisco land is too expensive to be
given to the dead and it has been for a
long time in the first decades of the
20th century all the hundred fifty
thousand bodies buried in San Francisco
were moved to one tale here
welcome to Colma just a few miles south
of San Francisco a town known as the
city of salt comas only a small place
but around three quarters of it is made
up of cemeteries about one and a half
thousand people live here along with
about one and a half million who don't
too much live here as just rest that
means the dead outnumber the living by
around a thousand to one and many of
those bodies were moved here from the
first resting place or the second or
their third the trouble was that San
Francisco ran out of room and banned new
burials the dead don't pay rent and the
living relatives don't really want to
either with no new one customers
arriving in San Francisco the old
graveyards there had no money for upkeep
and fell into ruin there were reports of
grave robbery of valuables or
occasionally of skeletons so fourteen
cemetery associations founded this town
as a place for the dead many of those
moved here were placed in mass graves
their tombstones sold to be used for
construction material or dumped in the
bay as breakwaters with no one's pay for
new funeral plots in more than a hundred
thousand bodies to move the folks doing
the job took shortcuts sometimes modern
construction work in San Francisco will
exhume dozens of bodies that the movers
missed so why go to the trouble of
moving them at all
thank well it was either move the bodies
immediately or deal with them while you
are digging the foundations for new
buildings anyway what else were they
going to do almost everyone has a fear
and disgust response to death for good
reasons and religion and tradition in
America then dictated that the dead must
be buried the Catholic Church wouldn't
allow cremation until decades later and
well there wasn't another option I'm
sure that comments on this video will
make all sorts of horror movie or zombie
apocalypse jokes and if you already done
that congratulations you're not original
but here's a different question
for you most people figure that cemetery
plots are forever if you choose to be
buried the spot where you're laid to
rest is permanently yours at least in
some sense of yours that's not true
already some areas of Europe are reusing
graves and eventually every headstones
going to wither away so here's my
question when does moving a body stop
being disrespect for the dead and start
being archeology